durante meses estos lugares sagrados de
nepal han sido testigos de una
peregrinación inusual
de jóvenes que cantan y bailan por los
lugares pintorescos del país mientras
graban contenidos para tiktok
esta tendencia ha hecho que lugares
emblemáticos como este templo de
katmandú se han invadidos por
adolescentes armados con sus teléfonos
viene a ver el templo pero sobre todo
para tiktok pero se destilda de molestos
los usuarios de tiktoken nepal tendrán
que buscar otros escenarios para sus
videos las autoridades de paletas han
prohibido el uso de la aplicación en
determinados lugares de interés como
este monumento budista en la capital
Esta es la prohibición de tiktok pueden
hacer fotos a veces aquí pero no el
tiktok los influenciadores llegaron
hasta este lugar para grabarse con
música a todo volumen día y noche
durante meses
usan palas de selfie y luego bailan y a
veces toda la multitud de gente también
hace el tiktok molestan a la gente que
camina que rinde culto aquí
pero también se ha prohibido en otros
lugares históricos del país ya que no
solo los lugares sagrados atraen a los
influencers nepalíes
los campos del centro de nepal también
se han convertido en un escenario
favorito este agricultor está harto
porque dice dañan sus cultivos
miren pasan por aquí y lo destruyen todo
pisotean todos mis brotes de arroz Pero
qué puedo hacer
esto les digo que se detengan que no
destruyan mis Campos Pero ellos siguen
bailando dicen que no están haciendo
nada malo
en los últimos dos años el número de
usuarios de tik token nepal ha aumentado
en casi un 2000 por